the United States has a responsibility
to ensure accountability to human rights
to prevent the ethnic cleansing of
Palestinians they are actually
apologists for terrorist organizations
they are usually a group of people who
have no sense of what the history is or
what reality is or what they would do if
their family was beheaded or their child
was burned to death uh and at the top of
that list I put these members of the
Hamas caucus and of course I'm talking
about AOC and ilhan Omar and Rashida
Talib there's about five others of them
uh here is a doing one of her little
handheld videos uh and she's very
concerned she has not called for the
release of the American hostages she has
basically not said anything uh other
than a little bit of lip service about
the dead Israelis she didn't share any
videos about the original attack
anything like that she's mostly
concerned the American responsibility
remember at least 20 American hostages
but the most thing that America should
care about right now it's the
responsibility to help the
Palestinians our
responsibility is to the stability and
the security of the region that means
being able to support uh not support yes
Israel in its defensive capacities right
in its abil in in in that context but it
also means that the United States has a
responsibility to ensure accountability
to human rights to prevent the ethnic
cleansing of Palestinians and to ensure
that Horrors do not happen in the names
of victims who do not want their tragedy
to be used to justify further violence
and Injustice right okay first of all
she farted at the end of that thing I
don't know if you heard that but that we
did not add that and many people have
done like forensic this is the beauty of
the internet even in in terrible times
she legit beefed at the end of that
thing so enjoy that that's and you know
considering that's what she's spewing
out of her mouth the whole time that's
not surprising so again her number one
uh concern is the responsib ability that
America will do something about the
Palestinians she has not asked for the
American hostages to be released think
how profoundly insane that is uh she
gets also very nervous when she has to
say anything remotely decent about
Israel but when she even says that they
should be you know in essence she's
saying we should help them defend
themselves well sometimes defense you
cannot play defense all the time with an
army occasionally you can't just always
be like okay they killed a couple of us
we'll kill a couple of them you can't
you can't do that if in a sport you
can't always be defense soccer you can't
always be on the defensive side of the
field basketball you can't always play
defense you got to score some points
every now and again that's how you win
right so sometimes a military has to do
things sometimes they would prefer not
to do them because they know that the
bad guys will use that so that useful
idiots will start screaming about ethnic
cleansing and everything
else